hello everyone and welcome back to the
1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament it's around 22 so the
penultimate round it's Swift was a big
leaguer rich versus Bobby Fischer now
it's been a wild tournament so far only
two more rounds to go and after you know
having a couple of winning streaks and a
couple of tough breaks Fischer is now
again on a winning streak he defeated
five of the five of his previous
opponents and now he faces the strongest
Yugoslavian Grandmaster so it was ugly
which which will be definitely a very
interesting game to you as again Fischer
will go for the Benoni
but before we head into that we do have
a nice photo challenge so best of luck
to everyone who is the person the chess
player in the photo here there you have
it it's a very nice photo by David Lada
and she did say on her Twitter profile
that this photo made her realized that
she is taking her chess tournaments way
too seriously and in addition you will
get extra points if you figure out why
she is in the photo challenge today I
will give you a little hint it is due to
her recent achievement so there you have
it now let's check out this game and
clicker which opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 so far an Indian game
Knight to c3 and now again the Fisher
goes for the benoni defense the five
this is the standard idea advancing the
D pawn captures captures in the d6
Knight to f3 g6e for Bishop to g7 Bishop
to e2 and Fischer castles legally to
castles and rook to e8 attacking d4 pawn
and here we have Knight to d2 a standard
idea and now both of the Knights are
guarding the e4 pawn Knight B to d7
preparing to bring the knight into the
center via 95 a4 always a useful move
against the Benoni to prevent any future
expansions on the Queen side
Knight to e5 and this Knight to e5 move
is always a very interesting if you're a
benoni player because of course you have
to wonder
can white push ETF for if white can push
f4 then there's no good reason to
actually play 95 but here and it's a
pretty standard position for the benoni
so you should probably
know that it's okay to play Knight to e5
because if you push up for here then
nice the g4 will be a very nice move for
black you're threatening Knights to e3
the fork the Queen and the rook also the
bishop is not defending the three square
as there is a knight and e2 and you
can't play something like Knight to c4
because you have to keep protecting the
e4 pawn as it is attacked twice so you
would have to capture here and after
Knight captures again you're threatening
the same idea okay Knight now white can
go something like Knight f3
but then black can go f5 and like
achieves pretty much everything black
hopes for when playing the Ben only
defense after captures captures it's a
wonderful position to play for black so
after Knight to e5 we have Queen to c2
which adds additional protection to d4
pawn and now f4 will definitely be an
idea so Fisher stops at g5 a peculiar
removed but it seems to be working in
this position Knight to f3 Fischer
captures Knight captures on f3 Bishop
captures on f3 and now h6 a bold
expansion on the Queen side from Fischer
saying that this is perfectly fine
butter to d2 simply continuing
development a6 and now Bishop back to e2
we have Queen to e7 rook a to e1
indirectly defending d4 pawn because now
if you capture the Knight captures
Knight captures you will get Queen
captures and then Bishop to d3 attacks
the Queen guards the h7 Square and
there's nothing black can do here if you
capture you lose the Queen it's a game
over if you move the Queen let's say
Queen here you get rook captures the h7
square is not available completely a
winning position for white so after rook
a to e1 Queen to e5 now Fischer is ready
to counter f4 with Queen to d4 check so
getting out of the way with tempo we
have king to h1 and now Queen to d4 the
Queen has infiltrated White's position
very nicely here but it can also get
very dangerous here we have f3 adding
further protection to d4 pawn and here
at night to h5 a very nice idea by
Fischer preparing Knight to f4 maybe
even Nigerian some variations but
this is definitely the critical one of
the critical moments of the game here
the queen is a very nicely placed on d4
but it's also a very dangerous square
for the Queen
because here the best move would be nice
to d1 threatening Bishop to c3 to win
Fischer's Queen as it would have no no
squares are left to go to but then
Bishop to d7 attacking the a4 porn so
now Bishop the c3 doesn't make all that
much sense Queen can simply capture on
a4 but after b3 defending then Fischer
would seem to go back create some
breathing space for the Queen and all
would be well
button licorice for some reason thought
that he can trap the Queen here or
perhaps he didn't think that perhaps he
simply thought that it was okay to give
up two pieces for the rook so he played
Knights the b5 a very nice idea
the queen is now under attack and the
same idea does not work here a measure
of the c3 will be a threat the Queen can
be captured here if you move the Queen
back then Knight the c7 forks the rooks
and you lose the game here so what can
you do here after a glitch plays nice to
b5 well Fischer simply to be denied a
captures on b5 and now the bishop to c3
doesn't work right away because Queen
can now capture on a4 so first Bishop
capture some b5 and now a bunch of the
c3 again becomes a threat and of course
the rook on e8 is undefended so here
okay if you capture here then it that
really makes no sense what was simply
capture the undefended broken e8 so
Fischer moved the Queen back 25 now we
have Bishop the c3 attacking the Queen
Queen does have a square now Queen e7
and Bishop captures on e8 grabbing the
undefended rook we have Queen captures
on e 8 and now Bishop captures on g7
team captures on g7 and now we have B
for trying to bust open here but doesn't
really doesn't really give black all
that much problems C capture some before
was played a glitter which goes Queen to
be to check Queen e5 Fisher immediately
offers the trade of Queens
Queen capture Sun before and now Knight
to f4 Fischer is now threatening Knight
2 D 3 this would fork the Queen and the
rook and of course win the game so rook
to d1
licorice prevents it and now we have b6f
fisher offers the b6 pawn so he can
capture the a four point and this is a
the best thing of for glee Guruji in
this position for example Queen captures
rook captures but it also contains a
little trap Fisher set for licorice
because now if a Glee which went for
this and played Queen to c6 with the
idea that he will win a piece here the
rook cannot go back as the Queen is also
guarding the eight square then Fischer
wins instantly with Queen to b2 and
there is no defense against Queen
captures and G to checkmate you can
prolong it for example Ruby Jiwon but
then comes Bishop to h3 piling up on the
G to pawn and after you capture the
bishop as there is no other move then
rook to a2 is coming and now no piece
can block Queen captures on h2 checkmate
so over a nice idea this b6 move by
Fischer trying to you know can get a GUI
GUI would wish to capture capture and
then go Queen c6 but probably in time
trouble which decides not to go for this
and perhaps he even saw this but he
didn't like the position even after just
exchanging pawns so here he played rook
to f2 but unfortunately for glitch rook
to f2 is a losing move so feel free to
pause the video here and continue Bobby
Fischer's legendary winning streak and
you know get him a win in a sixth win in
a row in the palm of America a 1970
intra zonal tournament I will give it a
couple of seconds if you want to decide
whether we want to do it or not so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just continued
Bobby Fischer's a legendary winning
streak and for those of you who just
want to enjoy it show here at Fischer
played nice to d3
once you see it it all becomes apparent
now the Queen and rook are forked you
will definitely lose at least the
exchange here because if you capture
then you get Queen to a one check and
the King has nowhere to go and however
you you try and block this you can see
that no piece can guard the other piece
and vice versa so after you give up all
of your pieces it will in the end be
checkmate so after night to d3
captured on v6 we have night captures
with Czech Queen captures and now crook
after Sunday for and this is now
completely resigned well glitch is up a
whole Bishop Fisheries up a whole public
or each has a pawn for for a piece so
you can easily resign the game here but
you know I guess it's better that you
know history remembers this game that
you know you lost the Bobby Fischer in
30 in 37 moves then in 30 moves I guess
so pink the g1 I will rope to a one
Fischer now once the trade rooks Queen
to e1 preparing to capture the rook on a
one rock to a 2 and now Queen to g3
offering a trade of Queens Fischer
avoids that although it's perfectly fine
to capture it Queen to be 2
we have h4 and now simply rook to a 1
and it was in this position unmoved 35
that glitch finally decided to resign
the game so yeah that's round 22 of the
1970 palma de mallorca inter zonal
tournament yet another great victory for
bobby fischer although this game is way
way below glitch skill level first you
know not going after that 91 move rather
he tried Knight B 5 and then either he
blundered it or he thought that maybe he
could push for something with with a
rook against 2 pieces and then in the
end that and that a rock to rock move
that wonder the exchange again way way
below click orig skill level but yeah
now it's a lot a lot of authors and a
lot of grandmaster said that Fischer won
the 1970 Palma de Mer inter-zonal
tournament by simply you know it's like
he's like psychologically impacted his
opponents that they played poorly
against him
but it is often a nickel towel off and
said that you know fortune favors the
strong and it always seems that you know
the stronger player is lucky he's not
lucky she's just playing better every
move and then if you if you don't play
as well as him every move then you will
lose the game of course at some point
but you know you should remember that
fortune always favors the strong so once
again I do hope you enjoyed it and that
here enjoying the coverage of the 1970
palma de mallorca inter-zonal tournament
so far we have one more round to go
there's a Fisher versus panel and that's
it now I would like to thank Chris
Buckland Mario Murat
Jacques bhisma Josef reader and the
Michel Acevedo
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it and for
those of you who are interested today is
the Boone's day project so later at some
9 and 7 p.m. Central European summer
time I will be opening some some packs
and perhaps making a nice hearthstone
video if you are interested in my
hearthstone channel as well and yeah
that's pretty much it and I wanted to
invite you today is yours or of the
birthday so I will put a link in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see it's his latest video
so feel free to check it out and
congratulate him or a rather a wish him
a happy birthday so that's it I think of
from watching and I'll see you soon